if  you see someone with crazy hair  well that's my grandpa and if  you hear some  singing from upstairs  it's only  grandpa all night long  the music played the  same old songs  but my grandpa's cool with me  sagada  let's all sing a hippie tune  i will sing my song for you  my grandpa talk  the clouds stick in my hair  and in my eyes  in 30 flavors i try to taste them all  i can't decide  which one is better the girl will smile  the whole day long and she  can see  why my grandpa's cool with me  psychedelic afternoon  let's all sing  i will sing my song for you  my grandpa talk to me  airplane  blue skies  chocolate justice  and fall in love and you  could see  why my grandpa's cool with me  psychedelic afternoon  let's all sing a happy tune  i will sing my song for you  my grandpa talk to me  to me  you